new york city
this is an amazing story so new york
city
is now going to phase out its gifted and
talented program and this is all part
and parcel of this desire for top down
control and a belief that a magical man
a six foot nine groundhog murder and
communist can fix all the problems so
long as you just give him total and
utter control over your life to make
things worse
so new york is phasing out its gifted
and talented program according to the
new york times mayor bill de blasio will
overhaul new york city's highly
selective racially segregated gifted and
talented education classes
and now notice how the new york times
covers that these classes are not
racially segregated there is not a
single law anywhere in america that
allows you to racially segregate classes
they're not racially segregated normally
when we speak about racial segregation
we talk about a government policy or
even a local policy or a private policy
that says black people hear white people
here no such policy exists in new york
city it's illegal it's a federal
violation of civil rights law to do that
it is not legal
under brown versus board and under the
civil rights act but according to the
new york times new york city like the
heart of liberalism is racially
segregating its classes that's not
actually what's happening
they say mayor bill de blasio will
overhaul new york city's highly
selective racially segregated gifted and
talented education classes a sea change
for the nation's largest public school
system that may amount to the mayor's
most significant act in the waning
months of his tenure the elementary
school gifted and talented program that
new york has known for the last several
decades will no longer exist for
incoming kindergarten students next fall
within a few years it will be eliminated
completely city officials told the new
york times students currently enrolled
in gifted classes will become the final
cohort in the existing system which will
be replaced by a program that offers
accelerated learning to all students in
the later years of elementary school the
gradual elimination of the existing
program will remove a major component of
what many consider to be the city's
two-tiered education system in which one
relatively small largely white and
asian-american group of students gain
access to the highest performing schools
while men black and latino children
remain in schools that are struggling
now notice what's happening here the
reason these highly gifted magnets are
quote unquote racially segregated which
they are not
is because there are tests given to
determine whether you get to go to a
gifted school or a magnet school
and it turns out white nation kids are
doing too well particularly asian kids
first of all pretty weird that we now
have racial segregation that includes
asians that's kind of strange that's
kind of a new addition kind of kills the
whole it's white versus black when asian
americans are making up a vast
disproportionate share of people in the
gifted programs
but what is this really about
what this is really about is black and
latino students in new york city are
scoring lower on the test than white and
asian american students so kill the test
kill the schools force those kids who
are doing better on the test to go back
to schools that are designed to teach
people who are performing less well on
tests
mediocrity equality through me
mediocrity is preferable
to
to flourishing through meritocracy
equality through mediocrity is
preferable to these command and control
asshats
to actual flourishing through
meritocracy
new york home to one of the most
racially segregated school systems in
the country like the new york times
thinks that if they just keep repeating
then that new york is forcibly racially
segregated it becomes true
it is not true it has never been true it
is not true right now
if the move represents one of mr de
blasio's most dramatic actions to combat
segregation in city schools it's just
amazing they're just going to repeat it
over and over though it also puts new
york more in line with how other cities
are approaching their own segregated
gifted classes about 75 percent of the
roughly 16 000 students in gifted
elementary school classes in new york
are white or asian americans
those groups make up about 25 of the
overall school system though the mayor
has long promised to tackle inequality
in city schools he has been criticized
by some for not taking more forceful
action on desegregation until the end of
his mayoralty
the change presents an unwelcome
challenge for mr de blasio's almost
certain successor eric adams a
democratic nominee for mayor who would
have to implement an entirely new gifted
education system during his first year
in office adams who is black by the way
has expressed skepticism about
overhauling the gifted system
instead he said he wanted to offer more
gifted programs in low-income
neighborhoods
but new york will no longer admit rising
kindergarten students into separate
gifted classes or schools starting next
fall instead the city will train all its
kindergarten teachers roughly 4 000
educators to accommodate students who
need accelerated learning within their
general education classrooms okay let me
just tell you this is not going to work
the reason it's not going to work is
because every educational study ever
done shows that the cohort of students
you hang out with makes a difference in
your academic development if you take a
gifted kid and you put the gifted kid in
with a non-gifted kid the gifted kid
does not make the other non-gifted kids
smarter the precise opposite happens
the teacher has to expend their energy
on the bulk of the classroom which is
not the gifted kid the gifted kid is
very often put in the corner handed an
algebra book and told learn it yourself
which is not effective
it isn't
okay i know this personally because i
went to a magnet school when i was in
junior high the kids that were
incredibly smart everybody was
accelerated and then i just come from a
private jewish day school which did not
have the capacity to handle its most
gifted students it's the reason we moved
to public school
and that's literally what happened the
math teacher came over and handed me an
algebra 2 book and said learn it because
she had to worry about the other kids in
the class
barring any dramatic moves by the
incoming administration
they are now going to
change the entire system the city does
not yet have an estimate for how much
the training will cost it'll be tens of
millions of dollars all
all because they want to avoid the basic
reality that some kids score better on
tests and some kids are smarter and some
kids are not as smart
okay period and that is not a race-based
statement that is an individual based
statement because tests aren't given to
races they are given to individuals
and if there are fewer individuals in a
given race who are doing poorly
like among asian americans fewer
individuals are doing poorly on the
tests so be it
using group data in to to fix individual
data is of course ridiculous and silly
but the idea is that these these guys
are so good they can hit a button and
not only will we get all the gifted
students to remain gifted all the all
the non-gifted students will become
gifted
all you have to do is give them the
power just give them the power to wreck
the system and they will fix the system
for you now none of them have ever fixed
the system
this is barack obama's entire stick he
got into office in 2008
and instead of like prior president
saying here's what i can do and here's
what i can't do he said i could do
anything except that these buffoons keep
getting in the way and bothering me
right it's these people on the right who
keep getting in my way i don't know bill
de blasio blames exactly considering the
entire city of new york is deep blue
but it doesn't matter the myth must be
maintained at all costs it must be
maintained
and what this is going to cause in the
end
is a continuation of the big sort that
we're seeing
there's a reason that tesla is now
moving to texas the reason that tesla is
moving to texas is because texas does
not believe that there ought to be some
god king who is appointed
to fix all problems
who ought to be the super ceo over tesla
in texas they say elon musk run his
company
and we ought to mind our own business
which is why elon musk is moving the
entire company over to texas
according to biz journals the ceo said
october 7th that tesla would now base
itself in central texas it has a 1.1
billion gigafactory rising in eastern
travis county
he said i'm excited that we are moving
our headquarters to austin texas
he said they still are going to have
plans in california
he says we're just going to increase our
our output from other places
this is going to be great to emphasize
again we're going to continue to expand
in california but even more so here in
texas there's a reason why they're doing
that the reason is because california is
trying to gain control once again all
about control
the the lie has to be maintained see
through the lie see through it they
cannot fix your problems the vast
majority of problems only you are
capable of fixing stop looking some
god-like politician who's really just a
venal jackass who wants power to fix
your problems joe biden ain't fixing
anybody's problems joe biden can't even
spit out a sentence at this point
here's joe biden today trying to read
his name from a teleprompter yeah it
didn't work out well
the ohio pennsylvania ohio pennsylvania
i'm from pennsylvania
the the the illinois president
of the don harmon
state senator laura murphy state rep
martin
moylan and we got great labor leaders
here too
tim
where's tim
there you go tim thank you
thank you pal aflcio state president and
jeff isaacson united brotherhood of
carpenters
and don finn ibw
and uh and robert writer
rita
reader r-e-i-t-e-r re-reader chicago
federational labor
okay so you you here you can either have
this dumb cup run your run your life or
you could run it yourself those are your
choices there's no third choice where
he's really good at this stuff i know
what you're thinking it's time to binge
some more ben shapiro videos well you
are right you should but first like and
subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video